JENNY BROWN: Today on
Cloud Storage Bytes,
we're going to use
our imaginations.
So picture a security camera.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Picture a security camera
capturing and storing footage
in case something goes wrong.
Every half second, the
camera takes and uploads
a photo to local
storage, conveniently
named with the time
stamp of the photo.
Batches of those
photos are regularly
uploaded to a
Google Cloud bucket
for display and analysis.
But there's trouble.
And no, not security trouble.
There's a backlog forming
from these uploads.
It's taking so long to upload
the local images on the camera
that they aren't getting
cleared out in time.
Delays like this max
out the local memory
and make the camera unreliable.
And that is some big trouble.
You've seen the
show before, so you
know there are
several things you
can do to prevent slowdowns,
like using parallel uploads
for small files.
But for this,
we're going to have
to dive in and learn
a little bit more
about how cloud storage
works under the hood
so that we can see what
else might be going on.
Let's start with what happens
when GCS uploads files.
When uploading a file
to cloud storage,
our friend the load balancer
is responsible for handling
the upload by deciding how
to distribute connections
between shards.
The secret sauce here is
that the load balancer
uses file names to
guide that distribution.
This means that the more
diverse the file names,
the better the system
can balance the load.
And conversely, the more
similar, the harder it
is to reach peak performance.
This means that if you have
files that are sequentially
named, like, say,
with a time stamp,
you're going to run into
this issue in a big way,
and that is exactly our issue.
The camera is using the
time stamp as the file name,
running right into this
performance problem.
Fortunately, the fix
is pretty simple.
We need to add some
noise to our file names.
That's right, noise,
a pseudo random hash
of the file name prepended
to the file name, which
will allow GCS to
better partition
the fixed range into
shards, improving our upload
performance without
clobbering our data.
This will almost certainly
get rid of that headache,
and there's more to come
about optimizing performance.
But we're going
to do you a favor
and save that for another time.
If you want to know more about
file naming and its impact,
check out the links
in the description.
And don't forget to
subscribe, give us a like,
and tell us what you want to
learn about cloud storage.
Thanks for joining us for this
quick byte of cloud storage.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]